so we've been telling you for months
about the mayhem engulfing america
streets crime rates have skyrocketed in
major cities as democrats simultaneously
pushed to defund police all across
america but tonight we have some good
news in the liberal war against law
enforcement
minneapolis the epicenter of the defund
police movement has done a complete 180
they have reversed
over a year of policies to defund the
police with their new city budget it
includes just over 191 million dollars
for the police department restoring its
funding to nearly the level it held
before george floyd was killed in 2020
so essentially minneapolis is right back
where they started from but
at what cost
in the months that the city council
looked to hamstring their own police
department countless lives were
needlessly
lost in minneapolis including
six-year-old anaya allen who was fatally
shot while eating mcdonald's
in her family car
or nine-year-old trinity addison smith
whose life was tragically shut
short while jumping on a trampoline at
her birthday party
these children were the cost of the
minneapolis city council chasing a trend
a perverted fad to buy off votes in
popularity
how did we get here let's take a look
back to the summer of 2020. it was a
feel-good time for the left full of
burning government buildings police cars
on fire utter lawlessness and it's an
era that democrats would fondly call the
summer of love
and to deal with that chaos engulfing
their streets liberal leaders had the
great idea
to defund their police departments now
as we told you
it didn't pan out it ended terribly
curbing the resources of your police
force didn't suddenly stop criminals and
as any
logical or
sentient person would know it had the
opposite effect in june of 2020 the
minneapolis city council had
quote unanimously approved a resolution
declaring the intent to create a
transformative new model for cultivating
safety
well
it proved disastrous since 2019 the last
full year before the defund movement
homicides in the city jumped from 37 to
79 while violent crime surged from just
over 3 700 to 4 800.
when it comes to murder that is 47 lives
that were needlessly lost 47 people 47
families that paid the price of that
perverted fad
so
after finally enduring this crime wave
they restored police funding now i'm
glad
i'm happy for the people of minneapolis
that they're more safe today than they
were before this movement but how do you
explain that
to the citizens who lost their loved
ones how do you explain that
to that 47 families
they just collateral damage
the price to pay and being popular
incurring a little more
a little more of your voting base now
it's not just minneapolis either how
about oakland oakland california also
acknowledged recently within the past
week the stupidity of the defund
movement just last week their city
council backtracked on cuts to police
funding and voted to add officers to the
streets why of course you know why
surging crime rates
again
i'm happy
for the people of oakland
but what was the price
just ask one
media crew how about the nbc sports crew
who was in the city this last weekend
they were robbed at gunpoint saturday
morning trying to do their job
to cover something in oakland it's not
isolated by the way this is the third
robbery of a news organization in
oakland in two and a half weeks time so
we've gotten to the point where the
media is part of the story but not in
their traditional way of being an
advocate in the media that takes place
here in studios here in new york city
but becoming a victim
in this story
they're now part of the story in oakland
and if you thought this was contained to
just violent crime think again how about
this the ceos of target best buy and cvs
and other retail chains they're asking
congress they wrote a letter to congress
asking for help
amid the surge in retail thrift from
their stores you've seen the smash and
grab videos by now you can't get
batteries i can't go to cvs without it
being locked up the deodorant is under
lock and key
these are the same companies by the way
that paid ransom to blm and now want
protection from the policies that they
paid for
at least the leaders in minneapolis and
oakland have come to their senses
they've taken the l
they've moved on
how about those ceos
here in new york city by the way
outgoing mayor
and world-renowned bigfoot impersonator
bill de blasio he's turning a blind eye
to crime
it's filled the streets of the big apple
under de blasio murders have jumped
significantly
from
269 that's back in 2017 up to
443 this year
still a couple of weeks to go
how does de blasio by the way respond to
that spike in murders
eight years i've been mayor uh indexed
crime major crimes in new york city down
11
over eight years
and we did it bringing police and
community closer together
so the key is to overcome this horrible
patch we've had in the covet era all
over this country the bottom line is
that there is to today in new york city
a much safer city than we were eight
years ago oh it's it's safer except for
you know
murder
and the families of the victims by the
way here in new york they know firsthand
that bill de blasio is lying and will
continue to lie now what's most
troubling about this is it's not new and
it wasn't unpredictable democrats have
historically been soft on crime not just
in big cities but all across this
country and the american people have
completely lost faith in the ability of
democrats to keep them safe look at this
poll from abc
36 of americans approve of the way joe
biden is handling crime 61 percent
disapprove
so how to bide in the democrats convince
people they can keep your streets safe
well maybe by starters they could
actually take crime seriously for
example maybe joe biden and kamala
harris could visit
waukesha wisconsin you remember waukesha
the site of the christmas parade
massacre described if you're confused on
cnn as a big car accident
it wasn't it was a massacre and the
white house is responding by sending in
the first lady jill biden and second
gentleman doug imhoff
to the site of this tragedy
now if you're one of the families of the
dancing grannies who were senselessly
murdered is that what you want to see is
that who you want to see the second
gentleman look i'm not
hating on doug here but can you think of
a title that carries less
gravitas
second gentleman
by the way
could you pick doug imhoff out of a
lineup
let's try
take a look here which one of those guys
is doug imhoff just
pick one can you really do it without
going to google right now
i think it's not the one on the far
right
my suspicion is the people of waukesha
won't know who they're talking to either
and they'll have to be told oh it's the
second gentleman
look maybe if democrats took crime
seriously they would send someone in who
could actually change policy a
politician who cares a prosecutor
willing to prosecute crime or a radical
idea how about a cop
to stop crime before it happens how
about not the second gentleman how about
not
the second string
for a photo op hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else